julie uh big brother canada season nine
it happened
julie it's so wonderful to see you okay
how surprised are you that you were the
first one let go
hi yes i'm shocked i thought i was gonna
get caught
but this was just not my challenge so
just devastated i we're just
devastated too you are absolutely
amazing on the first few days of just
being there i mean
what was it like for you let's go back
for a second because there you are in
your mask you see erisa cox you walk
into the house you get to take it off
and then
just hug people and talk and have a
conversation
freely with new people how was it for
you
yes taking my mask off for the first
time and hugging people and touching
people
and interacting it was crazy it's been
so
long and deprived of like yeah
interaction so it was so nice to see
people
and feel people yeah and one thing that
was so great is that this
cast was just the house guests were all
just truly diverse
and you're part of change what does that
mean to you
being a part of change means a lot to me
you know being
a transgender person i haven't seen a
single one on the show
so i'm so honored that i get to be the
first one and represent
my community and break down barriers and
make sure we're all included in this
game
so it was just beautiful to see a cast
of diversity
and you had that moment you really did
you had a personal moment where you
shared your story in your journey
and that's going to help a lot of people
it's going to cause conversation for
people to talk about it
what does that mean for you to be able
to be so open in your first few days
being open means you know the world to
me i feel like like you said a lot of
people
need to hear this and be educated and
it's gonna open a lot of people's minds
and
hopefully a lot of acceptance in the
country and
hopefully around the world so uh it just
means a lot to me to be on here and
share my story
yeah thank you for sharing your story
it's going to mean a lot to a lot of
people out there
now the challenge like you said how hard
was it
you know what i i weigh 105 pounds i'm
just bone
and skin it was just definitely not the
challenge for me
if it was like a running one or climbing
up a wall
or jumping sliding or things i would
have been
a lot safer oh and then team defender
loses
and then the game plan is in place what
was your game plan going in
my game plan going to the house was okay
so i need i need muscle
i need brains sexy is this
and then we need a shoulder to cry on so
i was hoping like a four-person alliance
i was like there's gonna be no girls
alliance but
it was the opposite i found some great
amazing
women and folks and yeah
yeah the dolls alliance do you want that
doll's alliance to continue with brayden
and austin
absolutely the dolls so now that i'm
gone i'm hoping they
bring in victoria she was someone that i
could really
rely on she actually was the only one
who voted
to keep me in the house so she's
definitely a real one and i
was watching the live feed a little and
they were kind of connecting so
hopefully
those three are the dolls now
i love that and julie at one point you
said why do i have a big mouth
and you say i have the biggest amount do
you think that affected your game
i for that moment i don't think it did
affect my game too much because i'll
tell you why because josh was already
going around and telling the whole
entire house so eventually
josh would have gotten to latoya he
would have gone to tara he would have
gone to everyone to tell them
um so i was like maybe i can use it to
advantage and just let you know people
that i trusted know
but i knew i was gonna get around
anyways
and then singling out josh as the
weakest player do you think that was the
right thing to do
signaling out josh i felt like that was
the right thing to do
as long as it wasn't on me it was like
on anybody but me like i don't want to
go
home so josh was the first one to
technically
drop it but he did have like a couple
splashes in his whereas i only had one
so
i could see you know why i was
the weaker one and the tension between
you and latoya
uh did it end okay did you guys hug it
out at the end
did you have a good farewell
the tension with latoya so she
is like fishy what's going on so i did
go to her and i was like please hate me
like i'll look i'll keep you safe i have
numbers
but i think she's just set in stone and
i didn't know
i don't i didn't know what her lines was
with other people
so i just knew something was up her
sleeve
we did hug it out and you know i did hug
her at the end and
it was fine at the end of the day it was
just a game so
i wasn't too petty um what did you love
about the house
what did i like about the house yeah
i loved every aspect of it being like a
super fan of the show it was just nice
like i wanted to experience it i wanted
to sleep in a small room with
six people i wanted to you know shower
with the camera staring at me
i wanted to try sloth just everything
about the house was just
amazing it was truly an experience
i love that so who do you want to win at
the end
i want victoria to win she is bubbly
she is social she is funny she's strong
i feel like she's a
very well-rounded player but
i hope she doesn't get targeted by
trying to
keep me in the house so i'm a little bit
worried but i hope her social skill will
advance in the game i love that and who
do you would not want to win
i would not want josh or latoya to win
they were the reason i was quick
those two i want them out they need to
be on the block next to me girls i'm not
gonna be happy
so what was your experience like did you
enjoy it
i honestly enjoyed it a lot the
experience was great
i just first went out like i still had a
lot of outfits to
show i still where i wanted to play spin
the bottle
i wanted to get in more of more drama
it just wasn't my time to go but it is
what it is
you are amazing julie thank you for
everything you've done in the first few
days on big brother canada you really do
have an amazing spirit and energy and so
it sucks that you're the first one out
but at least we got to know you so thank
you so much
of course thank you so much i appreciate
it
you